peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à chaque fois que vous et r c'est ce que
nous avons fait la dernière fois je sois
toujours derrière vous enfoncez vous
bien ça dans la tête attendait arrêtez
vous n'avancez pas on n'a pas encore
dans les courants il ya des tas de
choses au bon milieu on va se casser la
figure
je commençais par ouvrir les volets ne
bougeait pas surtout pas je n'allais pas
partir qu'est ce qui va vous avez peur
allez rentrer avant sait très bien que
ne bougeait plus
enfin la lumière attendait comme ça
c'est encore mieux
y'a rien à faire vous voulez absolument
vous en aller chercher autre chose et
moi j'étais resté seul mais bon dieu
vous êtes pressé notre école est
vraiment et quand il sera là vous
pourrez partir et l'armoire je peux voir
transporter leur mort tout seul
lp/f au moins 200 kg à bien nous
attendrons que madame viennent quand
elle sera là nous partirons comme ça
c'est elle qui reste la seule ici mettez
tout ça les apartés caisse clients
encore en bas je voulais dire dans moins
aller au tout dernier voyage
mais vous êtes en tête et vous alors
vous n'avez pas compris que c'est
reparti je m'en vais avec vous je ne
peux pas laisser la maison ouverte
puisque je suis responsable
on va tout de même pas perdre son temps
rester ici la belle affaire
il vaut mieux perdre du temps en gagnant
de l'argent qu'elle gagne du temps en
perdant de l'argent
attendez un peu quelqu'un viendra vous
pour aller chercher l'or noir or un
cordon enfin pourquoi vous voulez pas
rester tout seul ici c'est mon affaire
je ne supporte pas la solitude
ah non monsieur y at il d'autres étages
au dessus allons messieurs la terrasse
est là rien n'est pas concierge dans cet
immeuble
j'ai demandé des renseignements une
femme sur le pas de la porte mais là
rien subir une femme à cheveux blancs
oui j'ai ma soeur est idiote elle est
idiote et voulu faire le métier de
concierge et non ses moi le pont soir
descend tout de suite vous désirez on
valoir au punch chercher larroy un petit
renseignement je n'ai pas une minute
mais attendez bon vieux monsieur dit
qu'il en a que pour une minute ou pas
c'est ici l'appartement que pascal
loiacono vient de
oui exactement monsieur n'est pas là ah
non monsieur il a loué l'appartement il
ya deux mois il a fait à portée des
meubles pour la salle à manger la
chambre à coucher sans jamais décidé à
l'occuper mais justement il envoyait
tout ça aujourd'hui a fait savoir que sa
femme et lui viendront finalement il
habitait à partir de ce soir sa femme
ouais et l'envoyer beaucoup de meubles
et objets de valeur les objets de valeur
pour apporter aux meubles y en a peu je
vous dis j'ai installé une chambre à
coucher une salle à manger et 7 ans
trêve mais ça ne suffit pas
l'appartement analyse les grandes pièces
18 pièces appartement fait nature du
palais vous voyez ces balcons 1 à 68
comme ça mais c'est d'appeler leur one
presque c'est un palais du xviie siècle
il celui qui l'a fait construire et
toyota roi il avait des soldats de lui
et quand ça lui chante et il faisait la
guerre à qui lui était antipathique
vous avez vu la cour rodrigues los del
rio cela fait construire pour une
superbe damoiselles dont il était
l'amant il voulait la précéder toute
l'année chaque soir dans une chambre
différente et c'est pourquoi le palais
comporte 366 pièces 365 et les années
bissextiles
pendant l'occupation français c'est
devenu la résidence de la cour de france
des turcs des suisses ce palais on a vu
de toutes les couleurs
et ce n'est pas fini c'est un portrait
demandé au premier étage par exemple
nous avons eu récemment des soldats
américains avec leurs familles ballet
historique historique parfaitement et
aujourd'hui c'est pascal loiacono qui a
loué cet appartement
haha trop bien paye-t-il par mois
d'ailleurs pour la porte j'ai dit un
jour à cette idiote tu as le perdre tu
veux le perdre non elle peut faire ce
qu'elle veut se distraire le marais dit
que sa blonde du port les enfants
pourront suivre leur chemin alors
qu'elle pense à peu elle 18 pièces
palais historique
vous avez vous un faille pour vous
servir l appel voilà cinq mille dire
faut absolument que je n'en retiens
particulier avec madame loiacono en
l'absence de son mari
je m'en allais mais je reviendrai ya
aujourd'hui deux maps and my quand vous
me direz madame et seule chez elle je
montrais d'accord faut revoir 18 chefs à
l'historique j'avais des nouvelles
perles tu va le perdre mais droit
hugues aufray oui je sais un peu de
patience
l'autre partie
une marchandise
voyons si quelqu'un vient mes respects
professeurs oui oui s'installe
aujourd'hui d'après moi et qu'elle
répond le coup cette nuit les lumières
ou à ce balcon à à l'autre adapter un
souci à non mais puisque vous le dit
personne ne peut en douter et et la tête
d'éléphant
depuis quand ne l'avez vous pas vu
depuis 20 jours
la fumée et reçoit avec les étincelles
et ils guerrier il s'est plus montré le
guerrier urbain personnellement je vous
lis confie l'appartement lui faire des
recommandations du propriétaire et je
m'en vais vous êtes là
[Applaudissements]
tu avais les larmes à portail
d'abandonner les charges dont
j'attendais que vous descendiez j'aurais
pu attendre longtemps sur apple nous a
interdit de descendre
il supporte pas la solitude oh quelle
drôle d'idée hewitt il sera face à elle
sur le balcon à face à face avant aux
ordres vous permettez professeur
bienvenue monsieur donnez moi tout ça on
est prêt selon alors vous avez fini par
vous décider à tous peut-on mettre ce
poulet ça nous aurions dû le tout elle
mangeait j'avais dit à ma femme elle a
pris en affection m'est tombé sur la
terrasse non
alors faudra vie qu'ont fait les ânes
sinon il saura y vas diable au corps et
bien la gueule bien belle promenade est
mort ah non si les m'a fait voir elle
est encore tout chaud wanning vient de
mourir à l'instant même où je suis entré
dans cette appartenance de mauvais
présages vous frappez pas mais je vous
avais de série 3 fort vous avez tout
fait sans vous en rendre compte
bah c'est possible mais pourtant écrit
gay il gigote est tellement qui
m'empêchait de marchés urbains comme un
ténor d'opéra alors je m'emporte
monsieur vous l'emportez mais pourquoi
pour moi je rien pour les morts vous les
mangez vivant non mais vous êtes un
monsieur chez les gens bien on ne mange
pas des poulets qui n'ont pas été tués
pour ça quand on ne connaît pas la cause
du décès mais aussi de quoi ce poulet et
or cette volaille est mort par asphyxie
en pleine santé c'est juste elle c'est
un accident indépendants de sa volonté
demain enfin le bouillon bon appétit
oui en attendant accrochons les au
balcon si vous voulez il ya un clou
justement bon ah bah oui justement il ya
un clou alors quoi tu vas passer la nuit
ici comme ça demain tu seras plus tendre
ce thème et damien oui tout à l'heure
elle finissait les derniers rangement
elle parlait avec la propriétaire de la
maison que nous les sondages de ces
toiles prétend qu'on lui a bouché le
lavabo qui a une fuite de gaz pour trois
pièces cuisine sans salle de bains sans
meuble et par dessus le marché dans son
appartement ce qui fait que nous
l'avions toujours sur le dos elle avait
l'audace de nous prendre 30 milliards
par mois et sans parler du gaz de
l'électricité des appointements du
concierge à propos monsieur nous
mettrons d'accord pour l'exposition
l'école
à oui oui bah oui c'est ça on en parle
on en reparlera du moment qu'on en parle
pourquoi bruno mettre d'accord tout de
suite c'est pas que j'étais absolument
mais j'ai besoin d'argent
ah oui vous dites n'est pas mon neveu
vous jure saisissent tient pas
sincèrement je n'y tiens pas mais c'est
une impasse en masse qu'est ce qu'un
vrai jusqu'à la fin des mois oui ça ou
et non vous avez raison ça j'ai bien
j'ai bien compris en ça ne vous
tracassez pas et on en reparlera et ben
jeunes gens c'est fini cette partie club
qu'est ce que nous attendons c'est un
noir bien ça tombe bien justement il est
5h30 on n'a encore rien près de misrata
on va voir un petit verre de vin en face
et qui remontera l'armoire après ça mais
dépêchez-vous - des doors ou si vous
voulez tout et il plaît aux gens
apprennent la familiarité les attend
mais il faut que je vous transmettent
les recommandations du propriétaire
ah oui oui moi aussi raphaël il faut que
je vous parle sérieusement je vous
écoute
voilà chez vous merci messieurs rafael
je suis pas fou personne dans si je suis
venu habiter dans cette maison c'est que
j'ai de bonnes raisons
et si au lieu de 18 pièces en avait
trouvé 36,72 j'y serais venu de la même
façon c'est vous qui déciderez vais pas
refaire je connais le mystère de cette
maison ou plus exactement la légende que
l'imagination populaire a créé depuis
des siècles le fantôme les bruits les
esprits les lumières les scènes
g ouais enfin toutes les toutes les
bêtises qu'on raconte m raphaël si nous
nous mettons d'accord pour l'avenir de
l'europe devrait pas quand vous en tirez
votre profit j'ai tout essayé dans ma
vie tous j'ai même été imprésario c'est
vous dire
rien rien n'a jamais réussi seulement je
suis marié je dois donc nourrir ma
famille il faut bien que moi même je le
pense et puis la vie est dure et
personne ne vous aide aussi quelqu'un
vous aide il ne le fait qu'une seule
fois pour bourdier pouvoir dire après
jetée le propriétaire m'a laissé cet
appartement gratuitement pour cinq ans
dans le but de le revaloriser temps bien
entendu il a d'abord fait des pieds et
des mains pour essayer de le louer
rosheim bienfaits des réparations et les
presser un argent fou
yan yan une affaire personne n'a jamais
revu non j'ai chez mon plan si je peux
rester ici ce que ce que je croyais
vraiment peur car décidément je ne crois
pas un mot de tout ce qu'on raconte
j'achète des meubles à crédit je loue et
je loue les champs que je fais de cette
maison une pension de famille vous
pouvez pas savoir ce que ce genre de
commerce pour apporter en ce moment ça
me fera vite une situation
alors je n'ai pas parlé à ma femme de
ces histoires de fantômes sinon elle
aurait refusé de venir habiter ici et je
vous demande de garder vis-à-vis d'elle
le secret le plus absolu
bien entendu le propriétaire m'a posé
des conditions que je respecterai et
scrupuleusement et moi j'ai été chargé
par le propriétaire en personne ne
voulait faire une série à
c'est précisément ce que je voulais vous
dire ne vous mettez pas en faute sinon
sperme appel aux hommes pendant une
heure le matin il dans le soir vous
devez vous pencher à tous les bals pour
de l'appartement pour bien montrer
aujourd'hui en face de la maison et
habitat ya 68 bangkok
je vais mourir de fatigue les ce sont
les conventions balle chaque matin à au
moins deux ou trois balcons de chacune
des quatre façades du palais vous devez
battre 4 ou 5 tapis les voisins
entendront ou verront ils se mettront la
main
bah oui ça je sais le propriétaire en a
déjà parlé son nom je suis très
embarrassé j'ai passé le jeu pas de
tapis demandez vous on vous en prêtera
bien au web et d'ailleurs je peux
prendre une veste une couverture
n'importe quoi l'important c'est que ça
fasse du bruit en vous penchant il faut
que vous sifflez y est et que vous
chantiez on doit vous voir rire au
balcon rires mais je vois que monsieur
avoir l'air d'un faux moi chanter je
veux bien on peut chanter à son wagon en
se rasant ou en rajustant sa cravate à
la morgue imparable la moldavie dames
enfin
et voici le plus important oui quand la
peur vous aura chassé de l'appartement
vous ne devrait dire à personne ce que
vous aurez vu ou entendu dans cette
maison ouais d'accord mais mais mais
mais mais vous inquiétez pas je pars bus
partira pas personne n'a jamais pu tenir
le prix si ceux qui ont voulu faire les
courageux ont fait la chute après quatre
ou cinq jours et ils courent encore où
et en valais que les gens sont tellement
naïf
ouais non mais dites moi mais vous
personnellement pouvez vous affirmer a
perdu quelque chose non et sur quelle
manifestation la légende se font-elles
témoin moi j'y crois pas bon je vous
avouerai quand même que je te pousse un
peu un peu tracassé
vous êtes entré vous aider si peur que
sans vous en rendre compte vous avez
tout fait maintenant je les ferais trop
fort et puis c'est tout alors avez vous
vu quelque chose oui je ne veux pas vous
impressionner mais la situation est
sérieuse
la légende veut une damoiselle aimé à la
folie pas un grand d'espagne et tout est
en relation avec un pari noble chevalier
charmant et généreux lorsque le grand
d'espagne
rodrigues los del rio ce qui te qui sait
ça c'est le nom de celui qui a fait
construire ce palais
lorsqu'il s'est rendu compte que ça
sentait mauvais pour la vie ça sentait
mauvais mais qu'est ce qu'ils sont et
mauvais j'avoue dire que le grand
d'espagne avait compris leur jeu ar
alors pour en avoir la certitude
il se dissimule les surprend il fait on
mûrit vif les deux amants dans la pièce
même où il avait commis le péché à aa
ont mûri en blu-ray vie alors il avait
déjà fait venir les maçons ils avaient
tous fait part et tout j'arrête là alors
la maman venue à l'élévation vannes est
une pierre sur l'autre le pire sur l'eau
non non pitié et 11 pour rien à faire
vous pouvez mourir il le maire monte
monte on joue à l'aide
fini plus rien le dites vous dites que
ça s'est passé dans une pièce de se
caler dans cet appartement mais on ne
sait pas laquelle
et peut-être même de cet appartement non
non non non il aura les dents et pas
fait ça dans l'entrée on ne peut pas
savoir avec les coutumes de l'époque
bonbons mais vous personnellement pouvez
vous affirmer avoir vu quelque chose de
vos propres yeux un vrai dire non à un
message dans cet appartement
on me tuerait que je ne le ferai pas
après le sang versé mavuba sert
c'était une merveille de jeune fille
quand nous avons utile qui est engagée
comme concierge
vous avez vu tomber des revenus non
comment est il devenu nous je connais
pas c'est comment c'est arrivé
cet appartement n'avait jamais été louée
malraux brasseur venait d'étendre le
linge sur la terrasse un jour qu'elle
était en haut nous avons entendu des
cris impressionnant
personne n'a jamais pu comprendre ce
qu'il s'était passé mais le fait est que
la pauvre petit est monté veille comme
une fleur et elle est redescendue l'avez
tous les cheveux blancs est idiote is
you tu me dionne est plus critique avant
highway alors elles étaient des êtres d
un petit nom mais c'est une femme est
alors les femmes sont crétine ne sont
pas des hommes
quand elle vous raconte l'événement de
ce matin là à me mais est ce qu'elle
peut raconter la chose oui elle raconte
tout et on n'y comprend rien fait la
monte un je vais essayer de faire parler
votre pauvre soeur et voir si je peux
reconstituer l'événement puisque je
descends je vais oublier des relevés
vous voir elle s'appelle carmela du bon
alors nous sommes bien d'accord
souvenez-vous des recommandations au
revoir monsieur et bonne chance mais
vous partez
naturellement la maison et à vous c'est
vous de locataires pour cinq ans soit de
faire un coup mais c'est vrai que je
dois h doit habiter ici
non je vous demande et je vous demandais
si vous partiez parce que je vois là
voilà je vois là j'aurais voulu que vous
accrocher ce petit oiseau balcon
rappelle très bien ça va très bien servi
d'heure avant tout des personnes
si ces quelques rangs quand tu es entré
dans l'appartement j'ai très nettement
entendu quelqu'un qui ait servi tu sais
comme moi mais qu'est-ce que vous
prendriez comme ça vous savez le
professeur santana qui sait me motive
c'est celui qui avait très grand palais
d'en face où saint nom pendant sept
maisons basses avec dans le grand palais
d'en face celui qui ont trop d'argent si
c'est flou c'est le professeur quang
thanh il donne des leçons particulières
les enfants il fait la classe à la
maison il était veuf mais il s'est
remarié il a perdu une soeur au
tremblement de terre de messine il
possède une petite propriété près de
salaire l'eau il a un frère qui vit en
amérique lui depuis trente deux ans et
souffrant du diabète ou raphaël
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que ça me
fasse
le nouveau locataire nous espérons bien
merci professeur s'il pouvait vous dise
quelle voie de sondage dont de lumière
sur la terrasse des étincelles
une tête d'éléphant un guerrier et qui
sait ce guerrier c'est un guerrier de
l'époque avec des plumes sur le casque
un grand sabre nu le cape blanche et une
trempe aux lèvres ils se promènent sur
le chemin de rendre du palais dont on
n'a pas revu depuis la fin de la guerre
oui robin ils sont venus ils ont dû le
démobiliser n'a vraiment pas de quoi
plaisantez monsieur bientôt c'est vous
qui m'ont racontées par exemple vous
entendrez pleuvoir tonnerre hitler
tempête froid neige un déluge
vous ouvrez le balcon un soleil radieux
ou bien que sais je
un matin vous vous réveillez dans une
bagnole maison baigné de soleil j'en ai
de paradis vous endossez avocat
steuplaît relais j vous mettez vos
petites chaussures blanches sortie du
palais alors la plume le plus à croire
que de la perte est oublié et vous en
verrez l'autre les farces qu'ils vont
vous faire sur ce jugement
monsieur permettez professeur permettent
ces professions alors c'est entendu je
vous envoie mason a j'oubliai le plus
important je dois vous prévenir
pour éviter toute équivoque ni doute
responsabilités qu'il peut disparaître
ici n'importe quoi vous deviez un
chapeau vous ne trouvez plus mous
joueurs cravate et surtout le
ravitaillement
alors si jamais il venait à disparaître
kate objet de valeur je ne veux pas
d'histoires
il ne vous viendrait jamais à l'esprit
de porter plainte pour vol ou se faire
rouer de coups c'est que vous avez
affaire à des fantômes des esprits ce
sont des gens qui ne plaisante pas
gifles coups de pied ou de tête pendant
vous descendez l'escalier par exemple un
point vous envoie la tête contre le mur
n'importait pas plate pour tous les vols
qui auront lieu dans cette maison ce
serait terrible pour vous sommes bien
d'accord
au revoir monsieur et bonne journée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un professeur tout est calme tout est
tranquille comme un an maintenant je
vais pas trop mais tapis parce que ma
femme va venir faut que je mette un peu
d'ordre
alors la monogamie l ouïe ci dessus de
bonne humeur
oui c'est une belle journée ben oui je
suis venu vous dire j'ai eu lieu au
balcon prend l'air un petit moment mais
je rentre tout de suite fait peur mais
de quoi moi peur mais pas du tout comme
comme des défenses tombent mais enfin
qu'est ce qui peut encore croire aux
fantômes à notre époque un peuple en
plein 21ème siècle non même vol
[Rires]
ah ah ah ah ah l'amour et vous la sphère
du concierge
non c'est inconcevable quand on entre
dans une maison
pensez-vous carmela la soeur du
concierge
vous avez compris ou non c'est non non
non je vous ai fait venir pas aussi êtes
vous demandé des renseignements sur les
sur les esprits que vous avez vues sur
la terrasse comme d'habitude je montais
la terrasse vous donne les neiges
j'entrais par cette peur je monte à part
cet escalier régulièrement chaque
semaine un samedi je ne me sentais pas
très bien j'avais mal dormi la nuit à
cause que jamais dans la paix albino
musique
[Musique]
topiol au jeu montait l'escalier est
poursuivi par cette musique jeunes de
modèles que ton la joie connaître dans
l'église voisine
je me tais l'escalier poursuivi par
cette musique je suis arrivé sur la
terrasse
maj et jamais une part des mois la
preuve comme je veux faire une petite
promenade vaut prendre un peu l'air je
veux aussi dire
je trouve ma mère moi j'y trouve mon
père mort ne doivent à peu de son papa
et de sa maman
j'ai tout le l'âge je vois tu toi tu
fais la queue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel point clos où est ce qu'on l'a même
monsieur ou est ce qu'on a mais on a la
main en laminant on le met on l'a mais
la voilà madame à traîne à la rentrée
sur la bière vu leurs maisons
ta chambre
elle est là qui a besoin de quelque
chose
6h maintenant des mois la valise oui
alors vous pouvez vous pouvez partir et
ah oui oui alors vous viendrez demain
pour l'argent que je vous dois encore
bon ben tant attendu à demain au
monsieur dame belle soirée
oui je vais descendre à mes deux jours
je vous appellerai encore besoin
non
je vais acheter un paquet de bougies
sinon on restera dans l'obscurité on n'a
pas encore donné l'électricité
maria c'est toi qui apportaient des
fleurs
non
eason ils te tuent me prend dans
sympathie m'accueille avec des fleurs je
vais aller acheter un paquet de bougies
belle journée il ya encore du soleil
[Applaudissements]
il est allé acheter ses bougies
comment il s'est monté dans l'ascenseur
g2 les 1000 livres aux déménageurs je me
suis enfermé dans l'armoire
je voulais plus tenir voilà deux jours
que nous ne voyons pas avec cette
histoire de déménagement il avais je pas
d'apporter au moins une fleur pour te
souhaiter la bienvenue dans tout nouvel
appartement je te réponds pas tu de la
vérité pourquoi je suis ici alors et
tous ces risques que tous ces dangers
pour quoi et pourquoi depuis un an et
demi et j'ai abandonné ma femme mes
enfants fans à vous jeter bien souvent
conseillé de rentrer chez toi dans ton
foyer ainsi tu seras qui tend vers ta
conscience ainsi tu n'aurais pas commis
le péché puisqu'on dit qu'il était chez
de suivre son instinct
tu te cacher est cependant tu veux aller
vers moi quand ton coeur qui portait la
joie qu'il a désiré qu'il a voulu qu'il
a eues mais les scrupules n'ont pas
tardé à venir alors tu as cru te mettre
en règle avec dieu en disant mon petit
alfred finissons-en retourne à ton foyer
à tes enfants et des marinas je respecte
tes idées mais tu connais les miennes et
s'il est vrai qu'on ne va pas changer du
jour au lendemain à l'organisation de
toute la vie sociale je me fais fort moi
de changer celle d'un petit groupe
humain le nôtre ma faim pourra faire sa
vie quant aux enfants ils suivront leurs
chemins sont déjà grands enjeux père
forte et 10 pour avoir manqué aux
engagements d'un contrat un chiffon de
papier qui nous enchaînent pour la vie
une signature qui vivons une
condamnation à mort non tu comprends moi
je veux bien payer mais toi viens avec
moi et mon mari
ton mari et humain dit qu'il avait
l'intention de louer les chambres
l'installer de pension il est le roi
asséchant il installera sa pension nous
lui fournirons les fonds ce cadre
convient c'est antichan peut très bien
servir de réception ici d'une radio avec
un électrophone à bel assortiment disque
là un grand canapé avec une table basse
des revues des journaux un comptoir
tient compte mois après le passé là mais
cette fenêtre gêne un peu mais en
supprimant les rideaux et en mettant
quelques plantes vertes ça pourrait
aller très bien oui bien des tentures
par tous les temps
ren clients qui arrivent clients tout
par son mari ils pensent que je ne
permet pas de parler ainsi
mon mari n'a pas de chance dans la vie
mais c'est un homme honnête
excuse moi ma petite marie est
maintenant venu me faire plaisir
toujours tu n'as pas manger j'ai pris
mon petit déjeuner je savais bien que
d'après le temps de manger à midi
tiens prends sans un peu il est encore
tienne j'ai aussi apporté un petit
paquet de gâteaux voilà un beau soir à
bâle
c'est un poulet rôti
oui c'est un poulet rôti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et alors ça quand on est napolitains ne
peut pas se priver du plaisir de rester
à un moment à son balcon ça pour rien au
monde je me passerais de venir prendre
mon café ici tranquillement après ma
petite heure de sieste c'est que je le
fais moi-même mon café deux de mes
propres mains
vous voyez j'ai une cafetière pour
quatre tasses peut même en faire six
et puis s'il étend son petit jusqu'à 8
pour les invités basile chez que le café
coûte cher ah non non non non ça ma
femme ma femme ne met pas dans tous ces
petits travaux non non ce sont des
choses que la principale elle et elle
est beaucoup plus jeune que moi vous
savez alors la nouvelle génération a
perdu ses habitudes qui sont en quelque
sorte de la philosophie de la vie et
puis d'ailleurs qui pourrai jamais me
faire un café comme je le fais moi-même
avait avec le même soin avec la même
science et que je ne néglige rien mais
sur le bec
non vous voyez le le bec
sur le but je mets ce petit bouchon de
papier et il n'a l'air de rien ce petit
bouchon mais c'est qu'il a son
importance la vapeur du premier café
c'est le meilleur ne se perd pas le
parfum reste à l'intérieur et imprègne
les parois de la cafetière
oui d'autre part professeur avant que
l'eau coule et d'après moi elle doit
bouillir trois ou quatre minutes au
moins avant que l'eau coule il faut
disposer dans la partie inférieure du
filtre une demi cuillerée de grains de
café à peine moulu s'était plaint d'un
petit secret que non mais n'ont pas pris
part et non mais non c'est pour qu'au
moment du retournement l'eau qui passe
en pleine ébullition soit déjà parfumé
elle même est arrivé aussi professeur
bah oui faut que ça nous amuse vous
faites la même chose à faire la même
chose à moi aussi
et qui plus est je fais moi-même la
torréfaction non non mais ça je voulais
dit ma femme ne met pas du tout dans ces
petits travaux voit aussi professeur
vous avez bien raison ce moment le plus
délicat c'est d'arrêter la cuisson juste
au moment où le café prend la couleur de
la robe d'un capucins 1 à west a c'est
qu'il sait qu'il ya une grande
satisfaction faire son café soi même
puis ça évite les disputes à 6 tenez par
exemple si le filtre elle supérieure
glisse des mains le mar se mélange au
café devient imbuvable
alors comme c'est moi qui les fais moi
même de mes propres mains je peux m'en
prendre à personne je me persuade que le
café bon quand même plus je le bois dit
- professeur vous pouvez pas me faire le
plaisir d'en accepter une tasse vraiment
jeunesse je n'assiste pas aux quelles
merveilles à ça alors ça c'est du café
on dirait du chocolat
vous voyez profession comme il faut peu
de choses pour rendre un homme heureux
un venir prendre une bonne petite tasse
de café tranquillement à son balcon en
compagnie d'un voisin sympathique parce
que vous n'êtes pas sympathique
professeur sympathique
oui je me réserve une demi temps 103 de
cigarettes comment qu'est ce que vous
dites non je me suis je proviens je
crois bien entendu ah ah oui oh ouais
rien mais ce sont des bêtises j ai
jamais cru sinon je serais jamais venu
habiter ici fans puissent huit mois que
j'ai installé dans cet appartement
j'aurais dû voir quelque chose coop mais
qu'est ce vous voulez que je vous dise
moi je n'ai pas que je me jeu non je ne
mets pas non jeu mais je comptais
laissez-moi par les professeurs je ne
mets pas en doute ce que vous dit je dis
simplement qu'il règne dans une maison
la plus grande tranquillité mais peu
m'importe que vous voyez sur la terrasse
le chemin de ronde où les balcons moi ce
que je vous affirme mois 1
c'est que cette maison m'a porté bonheur
depuis je suis installé ici mes affaires
vont beaucoup mieux
ma pension est prête à recevoir les
clients alors quand aux fantômes alors
ça je n'ai jamais vu c'est à dire
l'ombre d'un photo mais les journaux les
journaux messieurs le concierge
m'apporter journaux vous plaît vous
permettez professeurs tous les deux
portent annonce avoir
à pension loiacono 176 vos tribuna les
chambres tout confort cuisine trois
salles de bains prix modérés
propriétaire et gérant pascal loiacono
j'y comprends rien n'y a pas un seul
client et dont j'ai alerté tous les
courtiers toutes les agences rien à fait
fascinant ce monsieur gagnon ce n'est
pareil depuis trois jours wifi n'oublie
pas tout ce qu'on raconte sur cette
maison
mais avant que les gens réussissent à ne
plus y penser c'est tranquille
complètement fois du temps élevé est-ce
que vous bâti régulièrement les tapis
adressé mon intérêt vous m'avez entendu
ce matin un vrai tirs de dca et les
chansons hier au soir à la fois un site
et vous vous vous avez une très jolie
voix mais à partir d'une certaine heure
il vaut mieux cesser et des employés qui
habite paris c'est des gens qui se
lèvent de bonne heure et moi même je
commence très tôt mon service moi aussi
j'ai un service je veux qu'on sache que
j'habite cette maison et que je suis
content ce soir chantre et rigoletto la
tonne alors j'ai beau faire soyez
patients mais si tu mets des guillemets
c'est que je suis à bout de souffle mois
avec toutes les dépenses que j'ai
engagée si je ne commence pas récolter
ce que j'ai fait mais je lui dirai dans
la misère et vous avez un gros frais un
propos voici le compte de ce matin ville
viande légumes plus la tête d'hier les
au total de 1270 oui bah ça peut
produire et de 1270 dire qu'on mangeait
une journée mais dieu soir oui cela ça
je sais mais enfin c'est excessif
on payait tout de suite je vous paie
tout de suite je voudrais si je peux
sinon on en reparlera un raphaël
je n'en ai rien dit à personne et
pourtant j'ai tout intérêt à détruire la
légende le professeur me pose tout un
tas de questions
il voudrait tout savoir je suis muet
comme la tombe et pourtant les faits
sont là
je ne voulais pas y croire mais il a
bien fallu que je me rende à l'évidence
en papa peut pas de bruit insolites pas
de manifestation sinistres non non non
non rien que des gestes bienveillant il
faut croire qu'ils m'ont pris en
sympathie s'est passé
tenez par exemple quand j'entre dans une
pièce j'ai la sensation que quelqu'un
derrière moi passe dans la pièce à côté
une silhouette d'homme de 30 35 ans oui
moi aussi je devais monsieur faciale
surtout quand vous sortez vraiment au
début je lui demandais où ils allaient
et je leur demande encore ailleurs mais
il s'arrête devant moi me regardent
comme s'il voulait me dire comment vous
allez pas vous n'avez pas encore compris
où je vais et il monte
dorénavant il vaut mieux que je ne me
demande plus rien qu'en pensez vous
revenons à nos dirigeants ne lui pose
surtout pas de questions sadc le allait
venir comme il l'entend les faits sont
là
c'est pourtant c'est pas une veste
ordinaire c'est une vraie mine on y
trouve tout ce qu'on veut vraiment quand
je rentre à la maison le soir échos
jeuland au jeu n'est qu'à mettre la main
dans ma poche et billets de 50 200 et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je la
croche ici et maintenant gars à qui la
touche quelle merveille jeu par n
importe quel pas une veste seulement je
commence à m'inquiéter parce que la
source était tellement facile que j'ai
un peu exagéré pour avoir une pension
comme il faut j'ai fait faire trois
salles de bain j'ai versé un acompte
mais maintenant je me demande où je vais
pêcher le reste très bas chercher dans
les poches de cette fameuse mais je
cherche ce moment je n'y trouve plus que
des sommes insignifiante l'aide de la
menue monnaie
l'argent de poche j'ai cherché dans les
meubles à la tueuse
la cheminée dans le lit de madame mais
si vous vous imaginez que j'ai pas
fouillé partout alors qu'est ce que je
dois faire moi j'attends bien que celui
qui prête continue de payer va quand
même temps blessé que les baignoires sur
les bras ah oui ah oui à propos alors je
voudrais dire combien nous avons dit de
1262 dire
bon ben alors attendez voilà trois mille
lire en des mois la monnaie
[Musique]
exactement faut mieux le demander
directement à madame madame c'est ça je
vous appellerai n'ont pas besoin de
mettre à disposition merci beaucoup
alors permettez 3000 et ma monnaie un
abonné c'est ici à aller pour lille3000
et ses amis d'ici et comment est ce
possible j'en sais rien mais je vous
assure que je n'ai pas les 3000 lire
mais je vous affirme que j'ai pour mam
avait sept aps est une blague du fantôme
ouais c'est vrai que le fantôme s'amuse
il a dû mettre votre monnaie dans ma foi
je suis 10,3 me lire dans la voix
allez messieurs sortez les 3 mai lire ah
si vous ne sortez pas la monnaie on
reverra pas les 3000 lits retour paraît
au bien de réparer ce serait trop
injuste
oui on a beau connaître les phares de ce
sacré fantôme
ça vous épate toujours oui et
disparaissent du comptoir me retrouve
dans ma poche gauche c'est incroyable
sont les mêmes à pourvoir après le power
descendrait j'aimerais vous faire dans
votre approche il n'ya pas les 3 mai
lire ah oui vous avez raison il faut que
je regarde après ce qui s'est passé
la cepl à nom et à l'argent n'y est pas
parlons sérieusement monsieur j'ai tout
vu mais qu'est ce que vous avez vu le
premier livre sourire trottoirs et or
alors ils ont disparu même on est aussi
amené bruyneel a reparu mais pas les
3000 irène et son port paru aa
ça prouve que le fantôme vous attend
sympathie mon dieu je suis désolé baky
peut-on s'en prendre aux saïdis paraît
tellement de choses dans ma vision sans
covenant plaignent des cravates des
mouchoirs des melons ne vois pas du tout
ce nouveau volet dit elle en riant
raphaël rien
les 3000 nuire non pas reparu un point
c'est tout avec un vous en prendre aux
fantômes règle je m'en réjouis un
fantôme fait disparaître au 3010 qui
appartiennent à un pauvre bougre comme
moi il fait disparaître définitivement
sans lequel reparaissent seront te ça
prouve que c'est un fronton de
malhonnête
ça prouve que nous avons affaire au plus
ignobles des fantômes
voilà ce que vous êtes marien autant
savoir ce que tu as ça a pas l'air
contente si tu as quelque chose dit le
parle
crois moi il vaut mieux s'expliquer tu
préfères traîne en bas bien entendu je
le préférais toi aussi tu devrais le
préféré moi ma petite maria je te cache
rien oui sauf peut-être certaines
difficultés que je sais face à ger
certains projets aussi que je sais moi
même et extravagant mais que je dois
garder pour moi et j'ai eu tort oui oui
je tort car si j'avais eu le courage
d'en parler je me sentirais plus libre
plus calme plus tranquille et bien alors
parle moi mais c'est toi qui devrait
parler bas qui peut-on s'en prendre à ma
petite marie à la vie est dure
il arrive un moment où sans savoir
pourquoi on se fait l'un de l'autre une
opinion définitive qu'ils faussent les
idées c'est presque toujours comme ça
dans le mariage l'un se dit qu'il cesse
comme un femmes pensent de moi l'autre
qui sait comment mon mari me juge
pourquoi at-il fait telle chose quand il
serait si simple de dire pourquoi tu
fais ça ce serait plus clair est tout
irait mieux mais c'est langues
chacun va être supérieur à l'autre elle
doit parler la première il doit parler
le premier c'est ainsi que les
sentiments se refroidissent on se
supporte à peine puis on se supporte
plus
elles ont fini par se haïr non on march
comprends très bien l'orgueil surtout
chez une femme à la toiture exagéré tu
t'es enfermé dans ta coquilles comme un
escargot il parle
marie à part je dis pas toujours enfin
deux fois de temps en temps nous sommes
que veux tu de moi nous nous sommes
mariés il ya cinq ans nous comptions sur
des espoirs de réussite de victoire
comme tu disais ses espoirs nous ont
aidé à vivre dieu sait comment jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est encore sur l'espoir
que nous fondons notre avenir
tu dis que je ne parle pas tu devrais te
réjouir
je me suis je fais ce que tu veux que la
nôtre vis en ce moment d'où vient tout
cet argent c'est moi qui les a
commandées qui a ce qui est acquis mais
qu'est ce que ça peut te faire
les gens me questionne tout mari ne
parlent pas ils ne vous dit rien mais
les gens les gens ça les regarde pas les
gens non mais c'est normal quand je pars
se peut que je parle pas sont pas des
choses qui se disent il faut que je me
taise même devant voir et surtout devant
toi c'est ça qui te met de mauvaise
humeur maría je l'avais bien deviné tu
sais ma petite marie a tu veux savoir
autre chose mais c'est naturel vient
surtout une femme mais crois moi il ya
des choses qui vont y vaut mieux laisser
dans le dans le vague
quoi quoi tu est jalouse on le voit
alors ma rue non alors ne ne fait pas
l'enfant et chez moi le plaisir de
croire que ton mari n'est pas un
imbécile finalement nous avons réussi à
nous installer à peu près convenablement
par quels moyens
ça n'a pas d'importance mettons qu'un
bon génie nous aident et souhaitons
qu'il nous est de plus en plus tu es
heureuse je suis content qu est ce qu'on
peut espérer de mieux
alors d'après toi il faut profiter de
tout et se taire je suis pas idiot je te
dis qu'il faut se paie quel homme étude
est qu'elle sorte d'individu suspense
est vivre comment es tu fais tu
n'arrives une radio avec un électrophone
et une collection invraisemblable de
disques récents tu gardes le tout il
arriva
mais tu te tais il arrive des meubles
pour cinq chambres à coucher c'est une
fin qui les a apporté une vague en
brillant on trouvait là par hasard et
toi tu y es tu as de bonnes opinions 1
56 milliard aux accords frais qu'est ce
que c'est la baguette magique
dans ces conditions il n'y a plus qu'à
croire à la poule aux oeufs d'or au père
noël
pourquoi de métier pas été souillées
dans la cheminée fonds pour moi c'est
très commode
c'est l'orgueil d'une femme l'amour
propre qui finit par se révolter dire
qu'au début je m'imaginais que tu
pouvais être crédule que certaines
choses pouvaient échapper mais toi
systématiquement quoi qu'il nous arrive
pas qu on nous apporte à la maison qui
trouve tout naturel normal logique si on
te demande si tu sais qu'ils peuvent que
tu t'étonnes que je m'en soucie je suis
contente et heureuse il y a un bon génie
qui nous aide mais c'est une réagit plus
sur les arrivées là moi non je m'en fais
tu de geek c'est là qu'à rester avec les
jambes de mes fesses maï sont pas
ridicules soit pas surface soit pas
ridicule
et puis après tout si quelqu'un a droit
et des des explications ici permet moi
de te dire je serais plutôt mois
effectivement alors comme je n'en
demande pas l'incident est clos
ne t'inquiète pas pour moi ni pour la
façon dont l'argent nous arrive
nous ne risquons pas la prison il faut
que nous soyons bien d'accord tous les
deux dis toi bien que si je parle pas
c'est que j'ai de bonnes raisons de le
faire
je sais qu'ils paient je connais la
source
mais je peux pas je peux pas parler je
me suis renseigné auprès de personne
intelligente cultivée des gens qui se
sont trouvés dans la dans la même
situation que moi ils m'ont tous
félicités ils m'ont dit bravo
j'ai beaucoup de chance vous êtes un
homme heureux alors surtout ne parlez
pas taisez vous sinon sinon tout sera
fini écoute moi bien
si nous disons si nous disons clairement
les choses tu resteras pu avec moi tu te
sauveras puis je peux pas je peux pas
laisser passer cette aubaine quoi tu
pleures tu pleures mari a alors alors tu
crois vraiment qu'on aurait pu continuer
à vivre dans la misère et les privations
nous aimons toujours comme roméo et
juliette
- rêve en à cause du neuf et 3 sachant
pas qu'on attendrait une paire de bas
jour après jour mois après mois les
attend toujours déçu les emplois qu'on
vous fait ce père et et qu on vous
refuse
après avoir supporté toutes ces épreuves
après avoir renoncé aux désirs les plus
innocents nous aurions effacer notre
amertume dans une étreinte parfaite
amour tendresse pas selon volonté avec
le ventre creux moyens mais n'a pas été
possible avec le ventre creux je t'en
fais pas d'illusion roméo et juliette il
devait avoir l'argent est du devoir des
rangs qui nous sera disputé dès le
deuxième jeu
roméo j'ai besoin d'une terre de bain
juliette j'ai plus un sou à coeur mais à
l'instant même où un peu de bien-être
commencent à arriver dans la maison mais
la monte sur ses grands chevaux
alors je te le dis c'est pas fini à
l'avenir plus d'histoire parce que moi
maintenant je veux vivre je veux manger
boire je me maquille convenablement je
veux que crosby ni cigarette puis tous
les dimanches mais un bon coup à ton sur
la tête et est sur la table et tout ce
qu'il fera plaisir et que moi je suis en
difficulté en ce moment en mode une
faute 250 mille deux cent cinquante
mille livres 250 mes livres il ne faut
pas d'histoire je les veux on n'a qu'à
les mettre
on va tomber n'importe où ça m'est égal
je trouverai bien marché c'est 250 me
lire
tu es une femme qui doit exiger de bien
vivre tu es quelqu'un qui doit voir tout
ce qu'ils veulent tu as droit à voir des
jolies robes des bijoux des fourrures
moi même j'ai besoin d'un costume neuf
un prince de galles
on avait raillé enfin peu importe c'est
toi qui le choisira moi je sors je serai
de retour dans une demi heure au plus
tard je vais jusqu'à l'âge ans pour voir
s'il ya du nouveau pour la pour la
tension avant avant que le temps de
garde
[Applaudissements]
quelle honte
enfin j'espère que tu n'as plus tôt de
sa mentalité sur les sentiments qui
animent cet individu es tu voulais pas
me croire quand je dois parler tu
détourner la conversation je sentais que
je n'ai je ne voulais pas de choquer
mais c'est tellement répugnante fred
sans prix et cette coupe est vite moi
cette humiliation t'humilier toi mais
pour rien au monde je voudrais le faire
ma petite marie mais je voudrais
seulement que tu te rends compte que je
ne me trompais pas qu'elle au projet
sont parfaitement raisonnable il faut
les réaliser
je n'ai plus un droit c'est un devoir et
qu'est ce que nous attendons au plus tôt
laissé entre les mains de ce shoot 9
j'étais là j'ai entendu tout ce qu'il te
disais je te dire quel moment donné
j'étais tellement furieuse j'ai failli
descendre pour le gifler j'ai pas fini
je veux 250 millions je les vois une
monnaie faut toujours courir oui
beaucoup de poids sur la figure il
touche juste polis donné et que tu vas
rire j'ai tout préparé par temps
ensemble je crois tu que ce soit si
facile tu es marié alfred moi même j'ai
un mari
qu'arrivera-t-il si nous partons
ensemble ta femme s'adresserait à la
police ahmad marines en charge
nous ne pouvons surprendre et on nous
arrêterons exactement la police est fini
le beau roman d'amour reste ici marine
quant à toi si tu te permets de français
madame je te donne l'énergie gratuite et
gif est tombé bas pendant deux jours
sérieux je s'énerver comme ça j'ai été
me drai j'ai du mal à penser c'est
sûrement la fatigue c'est dieu seul sait
les lui que je passe par ta faute bien
entendu car j'ai passé sept jours à la
campagne pour tenir compagnie à ta femme
cette maison remplie de bestioles des
grillons des mauges des moustiques on ne
peut pas dire l'état de mes nerfs tassée
depuis je regarde par hasard entre mes
draps les arts les gros comme ça
bon je ferme les deux fenêtres et la
porte aux pâquis de ses chats je lui
assène un énorme coup de balai cession
de la marque ea ne crois pas que j'ai pu
mettre la main sur son cadavre les
portes et fenêtres fermées j'ai mis la
chambre sans dessus dessous rien dit
j'ai pas pu trouver le lézard
ça m'a fait une telle impression j'ai
pas pu fermer l'oeil de la nuit alors
j'ai toujours la sensation que le lézard
et sur moi mais comment tu fais pour
entrer ici par cet escalier et
l'escalier de la terrasse oui m
la terrasse communiquent par un petit
but avec le palais north face tu viens à
louer une chambre cinquième étage pour
faciliter un rapport avec madame des tic
a dit sa femme amy d'armida et comment
at-elle su parce que ma soeur se tait
quand tu parles mais c'est quoi comme la
question parce qu'elle est tranquille
soumises là tu crois vraiment l'avoir
calme et bien voulu la séquestrer et
torre del greco avec les enfants sous
prétexte de leur faire prendre des bains
de mer
on ne croit plus bas depuis septembre
sommes à la fin du mois d'octobre elle
est encore plus grand que ces sommes
je te trompes parmi d'art ne se
résignent pas elle souffre est plus que
nous pouvons le croire est à fait fini
par un détective privé qui ne peuvent en
faire un pas un geste sans qu'elle le
sache alfred ma soeur va ta femme
possède un plan détaillé de ce palais et
de l'appartement très loose change s'est
jusqu'à présent de tabac fait surprendre
par la police qui peut me remercier
je suis arrivé à la convaincre dès 8
heures à scandales qui oui enfin qui
compliquerait la situation aux femmes
pour femmes elle l'espère toujours ton
retour malheureuse elle est
méconnaissable
ces enfants eux-mêmes continuer à
maigrir car il souffre des tourments de
leur mère obligés de vivre dans une
maison sans confort et lui il s'est
évanoui harbaoui crise de nerfs et vous
laisse emprisonnée elle tombe et là tout
à coup été blessé au front les enfants
crient et pleurent est obligé la
compagnie à en pleine nuit à la
pharmacie c'est alfred je t'aime bien à
vous que j'ai toujours été à mon père
affectueux sans préjugés nous avons même
été jusqu'à faire des frenay l'ensemble
bon moi aussi chez marié m'arrive
d'avoir les défaillances alors toi tes
histoires je comprends pas genève valais
pour moi
écoute toi c'est tout tranché mais ta
seule excuse moi de plaisir et une fin
aussi ça ne peut pas durer gaston non
seulement les plutôt du genre nous
sommes mariés à ne jamais cesser de me
torturer sa jalousie un père prénommé
tout et rien à gaz commandé chose
d'indéfinissable dont j'ai en moi même
quelquefois quand je les 12 et j'étais
étudiant dans un petit patelin alors tu
sais les jeunes on se fait des idées
c'était une jeune fille de bonne famille
des gens bien oui le père est un
respectable professeur de musique
et puis petit à petit j'ai j'ai connu
son véritable caractère au regard de la
mairie ya certes un petit défaut je ne
supporte pas elle s'habille très bon
elle est persuadée qu'elle est jolie
voix et pour la faire entendre
elle exige ma complicité quand je
n'avance d'invités ou pire encore quand
nous allons chez des amis où je sais que
j'ai ce sont des petits détails
insignifiants mais mais c'est important
il est embêtante maniaque jalouse je
sais je sais je lui ai dit cent fois
laisse le tranquille tous veulent perdre
tu ne le perde mais elle m'a perdu gaza
alors je te jure bien qu'elle m'a perdue
je ne retournerai pas chez moi je dis
pas de bêtises et les enfants moi c'est
les enfants mais je ne les laisserai
manqué de rien je paierai ce qu'il faut
je nous nous mettrons d'accord
peu importe pourvu que ça finit plus de
baisser facilement de sa famille femme
et deux enfants
mais non je suis trop la situation via
mais tu peux te permettre des choses il
ya des limites à tout tu dépenses comme
un fou cette femme de mène à la ruine
je ne peux pas vous répondre car je suis
dans mon coeur je demande seulement de
modérer vos expressions sinon je me
verrais dans l'obligation de vous mettre
impatiente quitter cette maison soit un
jour à quel genre de femme d'affaires
narbonnais raté expression est on ne
savait rien de moi vous n'avez
absolument pas le droit de me chercher
je sais tout je peux vous juger et je
juge ronald mac row étudiants voilà ces
photomontages jean-marie dans ta tête tu
ferais mieux de te retirer gaston que ça
finira mal je fais ce qui me plaît et je
te permet à personne de se mêler des
affaires des idiots
pis il mais que voulez vous qui êtes
vous la porte puis j'ai fait une petite
apparition chez vous mais je vais
disparaître immédiatement d'accord qu'il
faut partir tout de suite
mais avant contraire de ce qu'ils
faisaient souvent comme vous me
connaissez pas bleu j'arrête unien
personnes à comment expliquez vous alors
non j'ai rien a ajouté vous êtes jarret
plusieurs personnages sont pas de mots
qui vous définissent plus exactement
oui bon ça sérieux chercher pour si vous
ne voyez rien c'est que vous ne voulez
pas voir
voyez vous êtes un homme vous nous
faites pas il est triste vraiment triste
de constater qu'un individu fait de
chair et d'os
tu serais c'était différent toutes les
saletés qui l'entourent ça un homme
c'est d'un triste individu m'a répondu
salo l'infini aux personnages répondent
ils disent quelque chose mais est ce que
vous êtes un homme vous nature alors je
suis un homme
mais vous avez dit que vous faisiez le
court tu peux apparition et que vous
aviez disparaître immédiatement alors
est ce que vous êtes un homme ou le
fantôme vous avez l'audace de présenter
le présenter si vous êtes un fantôme ça
va mais si vous êtes un homme alors moi
je vous crache ce qu'elle confierait
fait pas le clown allait sérieusement il
est vrai que ça ne nous arrange pas tout
ça trop mal mais quoi tout cela vous
l'ignorez d'avoir le savez rien mais les
avoir le plaisir de vous le dire en face
j'aurai cette satisfaction après tout ça
réveillera peut être en vous un soupçon
d'amour propre
s'il vous en reste un tant soit peu
l'argent vous dépensez et moodie par des
âmes si l'ensemble
vous voyez bien que cette info savez
vous pourquoi vous pouvez faire les
dépenses que vous faites et mener la vie
vous menez c'est parce que nouveaux
frais
photo pierre je vous le dis mon frère a
plus tard celle de nice a sonné jallet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur ce n'est pas une femme qui vous
parle ce n'est pas une famille que vous
avez devant vous se sont bien cinq
photos assez du coup je vous en prie
aime chez vous monsieur yves ya un an et
demi que je suis morte
ces deux adolescents où je tournais pas
ces deux adolescents arrête tout exprès
de me toise
ces deux adolescents disait ge sont deux
petits morts j'ai été tués alors que
j'aime mais au moment précis où les
vibrations de mon coeur de mon âme de
mes sens
vous comprenez touch est au paroxysme de
la parfaite de la parfaite faux
comprenez vous airbus vient pas fait du
parfait bonheur juste juste à ce moment
là j'ai été tuées au mur et vivre dans
une maison triste et froid c'est vous la
damoiselle j'étais jeune demoiselle une
vraie jeune fille
ma vie n'était qu'un sourire j'ignorais
le match je ne pensé combien les fleurs
la musique voilà quelle était ma vie un
papa oui au tce sadjedinia gabillon la
châtré bee movie où la chasse et me moby
lucho ingrate et disputé look ingrate
dispute à pied puis ouvrage elle aurait
pu coûter ma vie fred essor daiei maru
qui ferait des sceaux daniel martin oui
aux os x et nuit mme aubry
[Applaudissements]
jamais l'ombre du péché n'a effleuré mon
âme toi si tu continues tu reçois de
tarte
je suis je sais que vous n'écoutiez nos
repas je regardais le petit fantôme et à
allaoui avait votre vie était un sourire
jamais l'ombre du clocher ma vie n'était
qu'un sourire jamais l'ombre péché n'a
effleuré mono j'étais jeune et pas nous
et est depuis un an et demi je suis en
quarts elle commence à voir une migraine
[Musique]
le noble chevalier cinéma qui l'a voulu
il cherchait type désir est il que
pouvais-je faire le plus pour lui
avec moi il ne manquait de rien
il aimait tellement ce que je lui
faisais les épinards à la crème
les canaux les vars et le château vous
vous en mangez déjà à l'époque et
comment je roulais n'apporte moi même
j'en avais mal au poignet l'on dit que
c'était la saison à milan ac la saison
les poireaux et en mille feux et des
poivrons par ses amis c'est la saison
des aubergines et à millas parmesane a
pas la moindre taxe sur ses costumes
depuis pantalon logera propre dans la
poche
l'approché par finans cuir de russie
comme ils me dégoûtent un [ __ ]
répugnant personnage ça il du couchant
il m'abandonne avec ses deux têtes deux
petits mots que diable en pas il prétend
que je l'ennui jeu l'ennuie jeu l'ennuie
c'était une impression c'est parce que
je suis prévenu des boutons parce que je
te soit ça les goûts
oh bien sûr mais aussi comme un
alignement l'épaule seule avec ses deux
obsessions que je ne peux plus supporter
croyez moi et je suis la mère lui valent
et irisé et moi et moi
cela tend à terminator le mort de césar
je laisse a été gâchée qu'est-ce que
j'étais avant lui
voilà et avant avant nous dans cette
union jeunes eux connu que le purgatoire
et maintenant l'enfer quand je suis à
tous explique ce sont des âmes damnées
mais le paradis n'est jamais venu mais
il peut pas venus aux mains dans votre
gros mots avant notre mariage de devis
était déjà tourmenté est jaloux
retrouver le soir au cachette des
palpitations sites interdits à maison
défend des devoirs il avait bien raison
et qui le grand d'espagne
n'est ce pas oui celui qui s'était
aperçu que ça sentait mauvais quand vous
avez commis le péché je comprends
plaisanté me tournait en ridicule
vous avez le coeur monsieur de vous
moquer d'un groupe aussi lamentable
vous n'avez pas pitié dessus deux
créatures privé de caresses paternel
vous ne pouviez pas disparaître
pascal 7 pascal rien
comment pourrais je vous le cacher vous
appartenez au monde de la vérité c'est
tout je peux tout savoir
pascal holl iacono je sais que tu sais
je ne veux pas le croire car ce serait
monstrueux et si tu ne sais pas ouvre
les yeux car toi seul peut nous sauver
et nous apporter la paix pascal naud
iacono sauve nous bras ce simple geste
par un retour de conscience qu'ils
auront s'ils avouent tout comme il faut
je te plains sauver ses amis en pleine
d'humour fait ressusciter cette famille
ainsi nous serons tous sauvés
ah ah
à une bonne âme toute religion maisons
églises des charité chrétienne
tu les un serpent et tu veux une
tragédie un cadavre pourquoi on est le
drame at il savait bien dans cette
maison et je vous dirai toujours je suis
condamné team a perdu mais j'ai besoin
de 150 milliards du monde les ghettos je
n'aimais plus beaux jours l'enfer c'est
l'enfer je l'avais dit dumas terre tu va
le perdre
ça y est la technique mathis porte
qu'est ce que j'ai dit oh mon dieu pour
supporter une telle malédiction des
malédictions
tout est calme tout est tranquille
professeur rien mais ce sont des bêtises
mais ça n'existe pas les fantômes c'est
nous qui les avons inventé c'est nous
les fantômes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il avait un treizième succès qu il
attendait avec des mots seulement
tellement émouvant que non j'ai pas su
refuser à bonfol fred c'est la
mélancolie oui les deux lieux apathiques
était tellement gentilles à quoi j'ai
surtout dans sa dans sa famille non je
vous en suis reconnaissant au nom de ma
soeur surtout il ya enfin compris la
noblesse de votre âme je ne pouvais pas
agir autrement une salle de l'été une
stat et votre mari vous agitez que
jamais parfois il me fait peur il a des
dec beaucoup de dec la pension aurait pu
marcher quelques personnes sont déjà
venues mais il manque trop de choses
pour les ce2 ou se voir celui qui nous
installer les salles de bains nous
menace de saisie il ne s'est pas trouvé
un emploi de travailler
il essayait autrefois il a fait tous les
métiers pour vivre cette hausse a lui
réussi c'est tantôt nous maintenant
c'est seulement je ne le comprends pas
je vais remada il dit qu'il veut partir
ce soir il a fait sa valise expédier des
télégrammes pas par contre ils allaient
tous force par les rames
maintenant on se regarde plus refasse il
a simplement dit qu'il partait qu'il
allait à la recherche d'un ami monsieur
madame provoqué n'avait pas relancé
alfred pour lui soutirer de l'argent
non j'aime ton soit requis pour son
arrivée n'ont jamais un homme comme lui
on parle d'ailleurs il vaut mieux qu'il
parte avant ne risquera pas de rencontre
malheureuse donc madame comme je voulais
dit alfred voudrait voir ce soir il a
toujours cette chance là dans la maison
d'en face le vélo et pour un an
enfin il sera cette nuit malheureusement
ma soeur a très bien compris mais je lui
ai conseillé de fermer les yeux
la cave est reparti l'autre n'arrive à 9
heures c'est ce qu'il m'a dit très bien
très bien avaient fait descendre à 9h10
je l'accompagnerai puisera auprès de bo
de deux nouvelles forces au moins pour
quelques temps parfait et moi pas vous
ben vous aussi vous voulez vous c'est la
vie chacun porte sa foi pourriez vous à
vous plaindre aussi moineaux ou ma femme
et moi nous nous entendons très bien
la vérité c'est que j'ai la patience non
mais je suis conciliant mais que
voulez-vous qu'elle sache de la villa
pour c'est pas nous en d'être cloué au
lit au lit sur madame je voulais dire
chacun porte sa croix
il ya huit ans que ma femme est paralysé
prochainement je donnerai tout au monde
pour la voir de vous me comprenez
l'humeur s'en ressent elle veut voir
personne
toujours dans sa chambre à l'obscurité
elle parle à peine
que puis-je faire à cela je me suis
habitué à vivre seul
à 35 ans je suis pleinement desséché je
n'aurais jamais pensé et il faut bien
d'ailleurs que les aspirations se
modifie au contact de la réalité
ce niveau en ce qui le concerne il m'a
fallu une fameuse guerre jeunes
agréablement les voyages les
distractions raccompagne tout ça
non pourquoi vous êtes resté avec ses
bavardages
continuez continuez si vous en éprouvait
le besoin parler cela vous fera du bien
je n'ai parfois envie moi même merci
madame de temps en temps si vous le
voulez bien je viendrai vous voir ça ne
le dérange pas au contraire
et dans le coffre en open très
volontiers maintenant il faut que je
parte
merci je remercie beaucoup
au nom de ma soeur aussi
non aux pauvres yeux sont tristes
fatigué travailler votre souffrance ne
plus rien faire
merci il suffit parfois d'amour merci
[Applaudissements]
or femmes bas
et raphaël je vous en prie ne m'énervais
part j'ai déjà les nerfs à fleur de peau
chaque fois que j'entre dans cette
maison vont prométhéen papier ce papier
bleu vous savez bien que c'est une
citation et vous me le donne et avec
indifférence ou non avec avec une joie
intérieure
on dirait que ça vous fait plaisir et si
je rentrais d'une fois par jour dans
cette maison vous auriez dit citation à
me remettre
non mieux vous iriez envolée une 11e
vous iriez jusqu'au greffe de la justice
de paix volet des imprimés pour avoir le
plaisir de me le présenter qu'est ce que
je pourrais bien à faire de vos
hésitations les manger si on porte des
citations je bloque des citations je
vais le pouvoir de transformer les
situations à vienne 1900 à aujourd'hui
celui-ci vous installer des salles de
bains est en encore venu ça vous embête
1 je ne peux pas être un concierge sans
faire le métier de concierge
je suis concierge - c'est à moi de
naissance adresse en bas c'est moi le
concierge mon dieu que d'histoires mais
que d'histoires sow fait plaisir
provoque un scandale à scandale ben
ouais mais c'est le bonhomme de menwar
pas vous lui avez dit de revenir demain
tu réellement demain il fera encore une
autre histoire et l'humiliation d'un
déshonneur
abbas que c'est vous qui parlez de
déshonneur maintenant parfaitement j'ai
jamais été mêlé à des histoires aussi
lamentable et bien moi pascal loiacono
je préfère toutes ces histoires
lamentable à vos sales petits trafics
pascal zoute est reconnue vous m'avez
dit que vous aviez partir ce soir oui
quand il reviendra dans la loi n'y
trouvera pas prêtes à laugnac renoncer
face à bien vous savez une presse de
parler rien de médecins sclérosante
quelqu'un tu veux me faire taire c'est
bien que ça finira par le lis plus
terrible enfin je ne comprends pas on
vous a coupé le téléphone l'électricité
vous trouvez plus rien dans les poches
de la veste
alors qu'est ce que vous attendez
abandonner la maison partir je partirai
quand je voudrais un jeu balle est
appelée matin le soir vous m'entendez
chanter vous n'avez rien à dire je suis
plus rien trouvé dans la fameuse veste
depuis le mode histoire des âmes damnées
depuis ce soir là il le sait plus et
montrer qu'ils le fantôme le noble sera
mais là il m'a plus rien laisser plus un
sou ce soir là toutes les armes de
l'enfer se sont déchaînés des injures
des gros mots peut être les mêmes que
nous employons dans la vie courante
remarquez ils sont allés disputer entre
eux il s'occupait pas de moi mais ils
ont dit ils ont dû exagérer on a dû les
mettre en pénitence mois depuis quinze
jours ci tombait malade une fièvre de
cheval je comprenais plus rien à rien
même une vessie de glace sur la tête
j'aime bien c'est moi qui avais acheté
la glace et les prix de ce jour là il a
pu reparler n'a pu rien laissé rien
naturellement c'était lui le bailleur de
fonds mais je sais bien c'est pour ça
que je m'en vais verra bien qui sera le
plus fort maria je pars pour eu pour une
affaire importante qui va peut-être
résoudre nos problèmes
j'ai emprunté la voiture d'un ami je
ferai une valise pour le corps sera
retardée alors voilà je te dis au revoir
je te dis revoir ma rires oui mais tu
m'embrasses pas tu ne souhaites pas bon
voyage
au revoir voilà où nous en sommes comme
c'est triste
l'amour qui meurt depuis des mois et des
mois nous n'avons pas échangé un mot une
seule pensée des étrangers et dire que
toutes les fois qu'on sort ya du danger
on peut passer sous une auto est écrasé
par un camion recevoir une balle de
revolver bas on sait jamais une erreur
on saman risque toutes les fois de
jamais se voir
oui on finit par s'y habituer
il ya longtemps que j'ai pas entendu un
mot gentil donc tout oublier mario quand
nous étions amoureux nous nous
regardions dans les yeux sans dire un
mot par timidité même nous nous disions
tant de choses dans le silence
[Musique]
dire que j'étais malheureux d'être si
maladroit de me sentir si peu de choses
près victoire mais c'est quand on se
sent maladroit que tout devient facile
dans la vie agréable on rit tout
plaisante on s'amuse n'a rien qui te
rappelle
peut-être notre coeur est il plein
d'amertume de tristesse et de larmes
parce que nous ne sommes plus capables
d'avoir un vers l'autre un élan spontané
je suis très triste
et
et si nous faisions un effort de
compréhension ne fût ce qu'un pas l'un
vers l'autre
mais non rien aucune communication n'est
plus possible la porte est fermée
verrouillé on sait plus où est la clé
c'est ce qui nous est arrivé et marie à
nous avons perdu la clé mon nom je le
portel moi même comme cette triste
marièrent comme c'est triste
[Applaudissements]
madame j'ai tout compris
il parle de la clé du coeur par d'une
vraie calais c'est une espèce de
comparaison entre une clé réel une
fausse clé est la clé du coeur donc la
clairière
il arrive que la vie conjugale finissent
par être lassante
mais c'est bien normal aujourd'hui je te
vois ce soir je te vois demain je te
verrai j'ouvre les yeux le matin je te
vois tu vois tu ton côté tu ouvres les
yeux c'est moi que tu vois le voyons à
noël le voyons importe on est rassasié
dia vi a fini par donner la nausée
c'est qu'on vient ici on aime
différemment je n'ai plus de la passion
du caprice mais quelque chose de plus
consistant
les fables d'un comprennent port elles
ont toujours des idées romanesque elle
aime les petites attentions les petites
gentillesse et si on leur en voudra
moins ça les attriste vous pouvez
toujours leur parle où elle leur est
pour une pente et c'est ce qu'il ya de
pire
ma pauvre femme était comme ça mais
j'arrivais à le faire parler parce que
je l'aimais
dès qu'il devenait mélancolique de
qu'elle ne m'adressait plus la parole et
ben très gentiment je lui donnais
quelques bonnes paires de gifles
quelquefois je te dis un peu dur mais
elle parlait alors je m'en souviens très
bien
pauvre femme elle se jeter à mon cou et
se réfugier dans mes bras elle
m'embrasse est ma figure été inondé ses
larmes et du sang qui coulait de son les
dames c'est ce qui vous manque vous avez
besoin de quelques bonnes paires de
gifles ça vous ferait du bien et même
saigner du nez ce serait bon pour vous
sur ce même je descends si vous arrivez
joies de la moindre chose ne vous avez
été appelé moi que je ne me sens pas
très bien marché et des douleurs me sens
bien que l'été mais quand vient l'hiver
enfin si vous avez besoin de quelque
chose vous n'avez rien appris on rend
malade
[Applaudissements]
l'étoile à 3 tarde pas pour ma femme
attend oui on a organisé une soirée nous
allons théâtre c'est comme elle elle
peut pas à tenir à ce soir la maison la
bougeotte
marie je ne peux pas te parler mon
fondement mon frère me surveille et 7
comprendre je te préparer la voiture
l'argent tout va mettre ton manteau il
revient à paris oui arrêté
il faut il faut que je vous parle or je
tremble comme une feuille
mon coeur me dit rien au coeur je fais
mourir c'est fait semblant de partir
j'espérais bien vous revoir cette nuit
ça je le savais je savais que vous
pouviez pas m'avoir abandonné quand je
suis arrivé dans cette maison on m'a dit
qu'il y avait les fantômes
j ai pas cru non je vous demande pardon
puis je vous ai vu j ai cru et
maintenant je vous parle je me sens plus
fort on a prêté cette maison dans le but
de la revaloriser j'ai rien dit à ma
femme pour parler frayer sinon on ne
serait jamais venu habiter ici ou
d'ailleurs vous m'avez aidé de l'argent
autant que j'en ai voulu
et puis du jour au lendemain vous avez
disparu en train de vie auquel vous
m'avez habitué je pouvais pas continuer
à le mener tout seul aidez-moi continuer
de m'aider vous êtes une âme bonne vous
devez me comprendre moi j'ai échappé pu
acheter à ma femme un bracelet ou une
bague même pour son anniversaire
ces mêmes quelquefois été obligé de lui
refuser une paire de bas vous pouvez pas
savoir comme c'est triste comme c'est
humiliant pour un même de cacher sa
pauvreté dans une blague est l'histoire
d'une petite boutade le travail honnête
c'est très dur
puis c'est mal payés puis on n'en trouve
pas toujours
alors je la perds je la perds chaque
jour davantage et je peux pas perdre
mari
je ne veux pas la perdre marie assez ma
vie vous comprenez alors j'ai pas le
courage de le lui dire sans argent car
c'est l'argent qui donne le courage sans
argent on est timide créatif d'une
timidité agressive naissante et des mois
qu'il ya des moments où il faut que
l'amour se matérialise dans un objet
qu'ils fassent plaisir en bracelets et
bagues jolie robe ou petite chemise de
soie
sans cela tout se perd tout disparaît
tout meurt avec un homme un homme comme
moi fait de chez red bull orange aurait
jamais parlé mais avec vous ses
différends avec vous c'est autre chose
vous pouvez tout comprendre vous êtes au
dessus de tout vous coupez vous pouvez
comprendre l'amour l'égoïsme l'envi le
mans sont rouges
avez-vous je me sens petit tout petit je
me sens comme plus près de dieu et cette
sensation de ne plus exister le fait du
bien je me sens comme libérée des soucis
de la vie quotidienne qui me prive est
tellement aidé moi merci
vous m'avez délivrer de ma condamnation
j'étais content à les hanter cette
maison jusqu'au moment où un homme
parlerait comme vous venez de le faire
si un jour par hasard vous rencontrer
l'homme dont j'ai pris les traits
n'essayez pas de lui parler il ne vous
reconnaîtrai pas sur la table
vous regarderez sur la table le moment
de disparaître est venu pour moi le
reverrai jamais
m
le disparu
professeur professeur ce que c'est vous
qui avez raison les fantômes existent
j'ai une photo je lui ai parlé comme
vous me l'avez conseiller m'a laissé de
l'argent
moi j'ai cru que j'allais l'attendre
toute la nuit qu'il est venu presque
tout de suite mais mais il m'a dit qu'il
était délivré de sa condamnation et que
je le reverrai jamais plus pardon sous
un autre aspect sous d'autres traits
c'est possible professeurs
c'est possible si nous l'espérons bien
professeurs
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous avons le plaisir de
jouer ce soir pour vous et de eduardo
defilippo
[Applaudissements]
l'adaptation française et la mise en
scène sont de jean michaud
le décor de roger hart
les costumes de donald cardwell
avec edith caire
banias vite mais ce kit
laurent douille m
jean de léaz
[Applaudissements]
pierre apter
monique thierry
[Applaudissements]
bertrand go
jean rougerie
[Applaudissements]
lynette lemercier
envie jacques let
jacques marin
et honnête là
et dominique paturel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je